you
[Music]
all right thanks everybody for coming
and thanks for today's chitchat for
coming to give us a talk it's nice that
many of you were able to come attend
this he is a systems student working on
formal verification of software at the
in the MIT advised by franz kasich and
nikolai zelda which there's still some
space on his schedule if later this
afternoon though you'd like to talk to
him come to me and I will arrange a spot
on schedule
so let's hear from Jay thanks Jay
so to motivate why we're talking about
layered storage systems let me start
with a story so the story will
tragically lack modularity but then our
GoSee will come in and fix that the
story starts with Bob a store system
developer who is writing a replication
system the replication system takes two
discs that are unreliable and it exports
a single logical disk with reliability
the way it works is as writes come in it
writes them to both disks and that
ensures that your data is safe even if
one of these disks fails now this is a
stored system so Bob wants it to be able
to handle crashes at any time say due to
a power failure and the problem is that
if the system crashes in the middle of a
write operation then it leaves the disks
in an inconsistent state so Bob knows
how to handle this he writes a
replication a recovery procedure that
copies from the first disk to the second
and that restores the invariance of the
system now bob is a careful guy so he
writes a machine check proof of
correctness that his code is correct
specifically that read and write are
atomic and have the right behavior as
long as you run rep recover after every
crash and because he's using the latest
verification infrastructure his proof
handles crashes during recovery itself
meanwhile Alice writes the right ahead
logging system that implements a
transactional API on top of a single
disk and she also proves her code
correct with the machine checked proof
of correctness with this log recovery
procedure now you look at this picture
and you think surely we can run the
right ahead log on top of the disk
replication system and we can prove that
composed implementation correct
the trouble is that the recovery
procedure to make this code correct
needs to run both of the underlying
recoveries and it turns out that this is
tricky to reason about formally so you
have a proof about what we have a proof
that each of these recovery procedures
is correct in isolation including
crashes during recovery crashes during
the composed recovery procedure don't
directly resemble crashes during either
of the sub recoveries so the challenge
is how do we actually reuse these proofs
and prior work it turns out can't do
this so a crash or logic our own work
from a verified file system has no way
to move from a proof about one recovery
procedure to improve about another you
can only have one recovery procedure at
a time
Edgar Sol similarly has no meta theory
for composing to recovery procedures
sort of implicitly assumes a global
recovery procedure and flash --ax while
they do support composition they place
some restrictions on recovery procedures
to make that proof go through and it
disallows both of these systems
this is rar Cosi comes in our go C
supports modular proofs where that
support exactly the style that we wanted
here where to developers independently
proof two implementations correct and
there's a generic theorem that the
composition is correct
including crashes during recovery um and
our go C is compatible with existing
techniques so we re implemented crash
Horta logic for the sake of this work in
order to prove the implementations
correct individually okay so the main
contribution in this work is recovery
refinement which is the approach that we
use to get modular proofs and also talk
if I have time about crash for logic
which is how we connect our GoSee to
crash or logic to proven a particular
implementation correct and see the paper
for details on an example that we
verified featuring right ahead logging
on top of replication the same example
I've been using and all of our code is
backed by machine check proofs in the
car proof assistant okay so and sorry I
should say that if you want to interrupt
me at any time feel free if you have
questions don't wait till the end so let
me go into a recovery refinement next to
explain recovery refinement I'll do so
in two steps first I'll talk about just
some background on how to prove normal
execution correctness using refinement
and then next I'll talk about how to
extend refinement with notions
crash and recovery to arrive at recovery
refinement okay so here's some
background on refinement before we get
into recovery refinement and refinement
the goal is to prove that an
implementation correctly implements some
exported interface say this single disk
in the case of replication on top of
some code interface that the code is
written against in this case these two
unreliable discs the replication system
implements every high-level operation
say a write in terms of the low-level
operations the in this case the right
implementation just writes to both disks
in turn and similarly for the other
operations in the interface so what does
it mean for this replication system to
be correct we define correctness based
on how you would use the replication
system specifically you take some piece
of code and you'd write it against the
disk interface and what you want to know
is that when you run this code on top of
two disks using the replication system
it behaves the right way if youhave the
way you expect the way we formalize that
is the standard idea of trace inclusion
where the specifications behaviors at
the disk layer should include all of the
running code behaviors at the two-disc
layer so that's just normal execution
but how do we prove this property
correct the way we do that is using an
abstraction relation this whole
technique is also called forward
simulation now this is all still
standard stuff cell background um so
with the forward simulation the
developer provides an abstraction
relation R which has two purposes first
it relates the states of the
specification to the states of the code
and also it enforces any invariants over
the code so in this case the replication
system maintains this invariant that the
two discs are equal then the developer
proves that for every execution of the
code there's a corresponding execution
of the specification that preserves the
abstraction relation and that lets you
run more pieces of code after this
operation and to get the full trace
inclusion property the developer just
needs to prove this for every operation
in the system okay so that's the back
that's all the background I have on
refinement now we'll extend all these
notions with crashes in recovery which
is the new part of this paper so here is
the picture that we had for an
implementation now we'll extend it so
the crashes in recovery recovery just
goes into the implementation but I've
also added these power symbols to both
interfaces these power symbols represent
the semantics of what happens
on crash for example volatile state is
cleared your memories wiped anything
that's in say buffered in your disk it
goes away so that just handles the
specification sorry that just handles
modeling crashes in recovery what about
the correctness for recovery we still
use trace inclusion but we'll extend it
with notions of crashes and recovery now
and to do that I'll introduce our crash
semantics to describe the specification
and then the recovery semantics to
describe what code we actually run the
crash semantics that we use is
intuitively it's a de Missa tee and the
way we formalize that is you can crash
before or after between any pair of
atomic operations and standard
assumptions for what's atomic are things
like four kilobyte writes or file system
operations you might assume are atomic
with respect to crashes and I'll
represent a crash in the middle of a
piece of code between any atomic
operations with this jagged edge
followed by a power symbol so that
handles the specification what about the
code we're definitely gonna run recovery
after a crash in the middle of the
implementation we know that the code we
need to do the code needs to do that but
we also want to model crashes during
recovery so we insert zero or more
iterations of crashes during recovery
first and that's all we need to specify
what trace inclusion with recovery is
it's normal execution plus correctness
under crashes and recovery how would we
prove this property we're still going to
use an idea that's like forward
simulation but let me introduce how we
how we come to the right condition so
the first observation we make is that if
you crash in the middle of some long
sequence of code you must crash in the
middle of some operation and in this
example execution that crash occurs in
the middle of op two and prior to that
crash you can just use normal execution
correctness to establish that the
abstraction relation is preserved up to
that point so we can sort of ignore that
because normal execution correctness
will already handle that what's the
specification for a crash during op two
we said it's atomicity so we simply use
either all of op to occurred and then
the system crashed or none of op two ran
and the system crashed and that
condition for all the operations is all
we need for recovery refinement so we
still have normal execution correctness
for non crash execution
we also have this new condition that
relates recovery to crashes improving
this for every operation the system is
sufficient to prove this strong trace
inclusion property for running arbitrary
pieces of code against the top level
interface okay so what I've talked about
so far only handles the single layer but
this talk was supposed to be about
layered storage systems so the work
we're the yeah it's a good question so
many systems would try to hide crashes
but we also want a reason about systems
like file systems that cannot hide
crashes from the caller just
fundamentally if you're running the code
on top of a file system and you crash
something will be lost or at least we're
going to lose track of what you were
doing so we want to be able to give
these weaker specifications if you go
off and you write some large distributed
system you'll probably try to hide
crashes basically you need to replicate
for that to work through the abstraction
of the high level system yeah and our is
my interface to do that ah
so our notification does not have our so
the specification should be that okay so
there's a distinction between so ours
talking about states the states are just
helpful to specify what the behavior of
a piece of code is but once you get to
the specification you only need to look
at the interface and the externally
visible behaviors which in this in our
system are return values but a natural
extension is things like the network
packets that you send out then you don't
need to worry about how are works
I grew a property about it about a
high-level trace yeah I want to conclude
something about a low-level trace yes
you have to somehow transport my
property across all right so ideally
your property should only be about it
should not be about States it should
only be about return values and if there
is something else that you care about
you should externalize it as IO behavior
of some sort the intermediate states
should be irrelevant I mean if that's
the intention of the system and I didn't
talk about this but you need you do need
to establish are initially as well right
it's an inductive invariant and you need
a base case it's just generally not
interesting but if you don't do that
then you would need to look at or you
wouldn't need to look closely at our to
make sure that it's actually satisfiable
okay so next I'll talk about the
composition theorem that lets us
actually take to recovery refinements
and compose them together for modularity
before I do that let me talk about
cleany algebra which is the approach
that we actually use to prove the
composition term so I've been using
these expressions informally in the talk
this alternation symbol on the star it
turns out that these are exactly the
operators of cleany algebra which is in
a formalism that generalizes regular
expressions so you can use all basically
all of your intuition from regular
expressions to think about these
operators we don't just have these
informally we give them a formal meaning
in terms of matching transitions of the
system so sequencing corresponds to
sequencing of transitions this
alternation symbol is non-deterministic
choice between two possibilities and the
star is 0 or more iterations and if you
look you'll see that these are exactly
the operators that we needed to define
the semantics of crashes and recovery so
cleaning algebra is quite closely it
seems like a good formulism to at least
model what's going on but it's actually
also useful for reasoning principles
claiming algebra has a rich theory for
when two expressions are equal and I'll
talk about that theory in a bit when I
go into the composition in terms proof
ok so let me just formalize like what
the modularity that we get is now that
we have recovery refinement I can more
precisely state what correct at what
composition is if we have
to recovery refinements that are stacked
like this then Argo C is a theorem that
says that the composed implementation is
also a recovery refinement and therefore
has this trace inclusion property where
that composition needs to run both
recovery procedures okay so before we
said we had this challenge of how do we
get a proof about the composed recovery
from both individual recoveries now I
can formalize a little bit more how we
might go about doing this reasoning
before I do that let me just abbreviate
these two with rap for the replication
system and log for the long existen just
to keep the slides a little less
cluttered okay so now we can formalize
what we mean at least by under crashes
it's zero or more iterations of crashes
during recovery before recovery finally
finishes here's an expression that
represents crashes during the composed
recovery and just to break this down a
little bit it starts with either we
could crash during the replication
system itself or the replication system
might fully recover but then we crash
during the logging recovery that's what
there's some number of iterations of
crashes during recovery and finally the
system stops crashing and the whole
composed recovery runs okay so this
doesn't seem any easier the top two
expressions don't show up in the bottom
expression but cleaning algebra can fix
that okay
so cleaning algebra has as I said it has
an equation Allah arethat let's just
rewrite these expressions to equivalent
ones so the first theorem we apply is a
theorem called D nesting which will let
us get rid of this alternation
altogether next we apply a theorem
called sliding and this might not seem
simpler but I'll go through why we why
this bottom expression is easier to
reason about cleaning algebra has told
us that it's exactly equivalent to the
original in terms of it matches exactly
the same transitions okay so after this
rewrite both of these proofs or to start
to apply before the parentheses the
replication proofs establishes that the
recovery procedure restores the
invariance of that system and then
within the parentheses the trace
inclusion property for the replication
system says this behaves like a crash
during the high-level logging recovery
code where from the perspective of the
replication system log recovery is just
another program that you wanted to run
that's all we need from the replication
proof then we can take what we now know
and plug it in
the right ahead logging proof which
shows that the logging system correctly
restores and the logging systems
recovery correctly restores its
invariance and the upshot is that at the
end of this compose recovery despite
crashes during recovery bullet systems
invariants are restored so I've talked
about this in terms of informally
restoring invariants but the paper and
especially the code formalized this more
precisely as a recovery refinement and
let me just give a small flavor of how
not only is cleaning algebra useful for
equational reasoning just rewriting
expressions to equivalent ones it also
actually lets us do refinement reasoning
so this little refinement diagram is
like the standard one that we've been
using to this talk um you can encode
this as an expression in clean e algebra
as a subset relationship between two
possible transitions there's just one
thing slightly weird going on in this
expression which is that we sort of run
our as if it were a program much like a
program R is also a relation between
trends between states and then that
subset is just another operator and
cleaning algebra that says that one say
one regular expression matches the
subset of one another regular expression
matches and cleaning algebra also has a
theory for reasoning about these subset
relationships okay so that was a lot of
abstract description of composition let
me just go back and motivate why you
might want this sort of modularity with
a real example from artwork so here's an
anecdote about where modularity failed
us in a prior in some prior work that we
did so we wrote this verified file
system called FS EQ and in one of those
papers we wanted to prove some
application correct on top of the
specification and that job fell to Franz
my adviser so Franz wanted to prove this
little snippet of code correct it's not
super important what it does all all
it's trying to do is atomically save a
file by first going through a temp file
and you wanted to prove that this is
atomic to make an atomic we need to run
this application specific recovery
procedure that cleans up the temp file
on crash and it turns out that this code
took a 1,500 line proof because of this
little FS recover that's hiding in the
application recovery procedure
so as I said crash for logic has no way
to move from a proof about one recovery
procedure in this case the whole system
is proven with FS recover as the global
recovery procedure we now we need to
move to a proof that has this recovery
procedure with one extra line of code
and proving that this is correct
basically required in lining the entire
proof redoing the entire proof that FS
recover handles crashes during recovery
FS recover is correct when composed with
on link and that this entire procedure
is the correct thing for Atomics AIDS so
we didn't redo a file system but in our
go see this should have been completely
trivial because you don't even observe
the lower levels recovery procedure when
you're reasoning about atomic save okay
so the story so far has had recovery
refinement and from recovery refinement
we've gotten two properties correctness
in the sense of trace inclusion and also
modularity because of the composition
theorem but I haven't talked about how
you'd actually establish a recovery
refinement in the first place given just
a program this is where a crash for
logic comes in so crash row logic is the
program logic from FS EQ which lets us
reason about crashes during during code
as well as during recovery so I'll
describe crash our logic which is the
mostly prior work but then it'll connect
back to our go see first I'll just give
a very brief overview of core logic in
one slide so the basis of core logic is
this statement called a halt ripple
which it's called triple because it's
three parts a precondition a post
condition and a piece of code and the
interpretation of this for triple is
that if you run the code in a state
satisfying P and it terminates then the
resulting state will satisfy Q so crash
row logic is just an extension or for
logic where instead of writing four
triples we write these crash
specifications that describe what
happens on crash we have an extra post a
sort of an extra post condition which is
a crash in variant which will hold
following a crash at any time during
this piece of code so that's just crash
core law that's just crash
specifications but we also want to
reason about recovery so crash core
logic is another statement called a
recovery specification that it
instead of just a piece of code it also
has a recovery procedure that you intend
to run and it describes what happens if
you crash in the middle of the piece of
cut in this code and you run recovery
including crashes during recovery so
here I just baked crashes in during
recovery into the definition that
doesn't help us prove this correct
so these crash specifications are pretty
easy to reason about because they chain
nicely if you crash in the beginning or
the end you're the new crash invariant
is gonna just be the or of the to crash
in variants these don't compose nicely
at all so how do we actually prove these
things correct so for that basically in
FAC Q and a again in our go C we prove a
theorem that lets us establish these
from just craft specifications so let me
show you what that theorem looks like
sort of diagrammatically so first you
write some crash spec for the code and
pre and post conditions just chain as
expected because that's just normal
execution and recovery doesn't even come
into the picture then you prove a crash
specification for recovery and the
interesting thing about the
specification is it should be idempotent
meaning that crashes during recovery
should apply the precondition for
recovery intuitively this is what you
want because if you crash during
recovery you're going to need to rerun
recovery then we just need to chain
these two together so when you crash in
the middle of the code you're going to
go into this recovery crash loop and
then finally when you stop crashing
we'll get this post per hat this post
wreck condition yeah and all we really
have to do in our GoSee is connect crash
for logic to recovery refinement we
still need an abstraction relation and
then all we actually need is to prove a
particular crash or logic recovery
specification using the standard
techniques of crash for logic and these
will encode recovery refinement and I'll
just show that graphically uh-oh there's
a build error
okay so the precondition is the
precondition for both of these recovery
both of these refinement diagrams that
there should exist some abstract state
satisfying our our is sort of also a
precondition and then the post condition
is the normal execution part of recovery
refinement well the recovery post
condition is the crashing recovery part
I've that I've de-emphasized these part
these these lower left parts because
they're actually baked into the
definition of what this recovery
specification means I'll skip this okay
so while well this crash role logic part
of our go see is fairly standard it does
complete the picture it actually lets us
prove programs correct in particular or
go see a crash role logic is what lets
us reason about crashes during recovery
for logging and for replication
separately okay so we didn't just write
a paper on this we also implemented and
verified all of this in the coq roof
assistant our framework is fairly small
as far as our systems go it's only about
3200 lines of code for the generic
theory by contrast and our example on
top of that is 4000 lines by contrast FS
EQ was like forty thousand lines of code
of which twenty thousand was the
framework and this example does extract
a Haskell and run all right our code is
open source let me briefly talk a little
bit about what some directions for
future work that we're actively working
on now so the first is the big
limitation of our go see is that it's
sequential it only supports sequential
storage systems so we're now working on
a story for crashes crash safety
combined with concurrency the way we're
doing that is instead of extending our
go see we're instead taking the ideas
from our go C and extending existing
concurrent in existing currency
infrastructure it's based on concurrent
separation logic a very old idea but a
very modern instantiation of it
in the frame and a framework called iris
iris has been used successfully for a
lot of concurrency projects with a long
line of Popple papers establishing the
framework and then many more papers with
applications but we are the first to
come up with crash safety techniques for
iris we also want a better story for
running code so currently in many of our
systems I have extracted two Haskell and
this gets us a lot of performance
problems I don't want to be too down on
Haskell but we lack control in this
workflow because we can't
really control the what the extracted
code looks like and get good performance
out of Haskell
especially when trying to do to get high
performance for concurrency one of the
things you need to do for example is
reduce memory allocations which is quite
hard to do and our new plan is instead
to import go into clock which I'm very
excited about this is a very fun thing
to do another thing that we're doing is
we are subjecting students to this oh
yeah sure I was like half ready to just
give us up a presentation on this but
I'm happy to talk about this offline so
it's not okay so it's a completely
trusted pipeline where I basically wrote
a small translator to translate a small
subset of go into clock instead of going
the other way around so we translate go
programs into some model in Cocke
essentially yes so I was actually fairly
general so Irish doesn't really come
into the picture of the specification
but we have a transition relation that
describes all of the operations that we
care about from go so heap operations
and file system operations because we
need to use the file system we translate
into our standard representation of
programs which is a shallow embedding
okay so we will subject we will in the
coming fall semester we will subject
students to this including Sydney
actually so Argos he actually spun off
from course infrastructure and now we
want a back port the improvements in our
go see you back to that course
infrastructure and for the sake of
students we basically need to make the
crash core logic part more usable and
make sure that the sole infrastructure
is a little bit easier to use okay so to
summarize I've talked about Argo C which
gives us modular proofs of layered
storage systems it appeals to claim
algebra both to model crashes and
recovery as well as four principles to
reason about the compensation theorem as
well as correctness
we've introduced recovery refinement
which is the approach that we use to get
all of these nice features and that it
gives us the right conditions to
establish tres inclusion for recovery
and finally I talked about how recovery
refinement also gives us modular Bruce
alexis composed implementations together
thanks and I'm happy to take more
questions lining system runs and crashes
yeah it can find it yes this yeah and so
and then you said well there's like
something yeah so this is a I
instantiate at this example with rep and
log with those two systems but we did a
single composition theorem for two
generic layers without ever looking at
what the layers actually do internally
yes yes that's just that's something
that you would have to prove if that's
something that you get from the fact
that the system is a recovery refinement
that's the only assumption that we make
okay there's some a tradition vote or
why they revived this for you just yeah
okay so yeah yeah it's because there's
this there's a small pun which is not
great on this example so that top part
is not a the thing that's being refined
is this is the logging the logging
recovery procedure compiled down to run
on top of the to disk interfaces using
the replication system right so before I
said that like code imple followed by
repression during recovery refines the
high level code um at the upper layer so
really what the really the refinement is
establishing is that the log recovery
procedure at the replication layer
behaves like a long recovery procedure
at the disk layer yeah
yeah you know for the use of this bit of
sample code that Brian Kenner writers
Dante added hundred and in our dozing
would they have to write it differently
like would they have to use FS recover
at all uh no you would not
so so you would express atomic copy
either as so you probably expressed from
this atomic copy example as a layer that
has one operation atomic save maybe
you'd also react sport all the file
system operations and then your recovery
procedure would not be able to mention
FS recover it would be added in in the
process of combining with the files it's
difficult you also another thing you get
for free is that unlink would become an
atomic operation whereas this unlink
call is actually a call to a bunch of
disk operations because it have to seek
you like everything is written against a
disk API there is no layering
yeah I'm curious about the in practice
what invariance you can use as the
invariant of a recovery procedure oh
yeah like the crash invariant is
invariant under you have a Cimmerian
that to get idempotency you require an
invariant and one really practice what
invariance you have yeah so the
replication system is fairly simple I
think so they're sort of a standard
trick which is if I were to finish
recovery now it would be correct that's
sort of like a standard in America
that's sort of the standard way to think
about what the invariance says sort of
that's like an always true statement in
the case of the replication system
because this is a sequential system and
everything is stable right away if you
crash you can only ever crash on the
middle of one right operation so we
actually the invariant is either the
disks are fully synchronized or they're
d synchronized at one point and recovery
basically finds that point in a loop in
the logging example it's a little bit
more complicated but similarly if you
crash we can basically ignore whatever
progress was made so far because
actually in reality we're gonna redo it
that's because we do physical walking so
it's fairly simple if you have there's
also like undo redo logging which is
more complicated where if you crash you
actually need to undo what you did
during recovery but I think similarly
you use this idea that if I were to
finish now I'd be okay and you just
prove that that's true for even the
things that you've done right now so
done so far things like you know
corruption of ideas from what you were
saying yeah you defer at most one
location that you're trying to find and
fix up right yes I another totally
trashed my drive I you know throw in a
bunch of cosmic rays whatever yeah then
this may not be true right yeah so in
the replication system that we have a a
model of how it's unreliable the model
says that at any time one of the disks
might go away entirely and then from
then on reads will fail when you try to
read from the
so if a disk fails then actually the
disks the disks are now synchronized and
so we can return we have to make this
assumption that only one disk can fail
because if both discs failed and clearly
you're screwed I think it's actually
like a big difficulty in proving
replication systems correct
is there not unconditionally correct you
have to rely on some assumption
any more questions
alright what's that
[Applause]